you
[Music]
this week on Q&A author Simon seabag
Montefiore he discusses his book the
Romanovs about the dynasty that ruled
Russia for over 300 years
[Music]
Simon seabag Montefiore the book is
called the Romanovs 1613 to 1918 and I
want to read you a headline in the Daily
Mail London Daily Mail you wrote this
back in January the red-hot Romanov
romance scandal of the married Tsar and
his 16 year old mistress revealed and
the raunchiest love letters ever written
by a head of state I have to say I
didn't actually write that right that's
the headline written by the Daily Mail
headline writer but I would say that the
correspondence they are referring to is
the most outrageous and most explicit
correspondence ever written by a head of
state and I have to say the
correspondence is some outrageous that
they added to the Daily Mail of mail on
Sunday inning the rang me up and said
you know we're a tabloid newspaper in
England but we can't print all this
stuff we're a family newspaper who was
it who is there china state well the
head of state was Czar Emperor Alexander
the second the Emperor who liberated the
serfs the slaves of Russia at exactly
the same time 1861 as your President
Lincoln was about to liberate the slaves
of America and the two men were actually
in correspondence and vote for them were
assassinated so interesting interesting
relationship that for a start and an
example the second was written the most
sympathetic of all the Romanovs in this
book I think and he also he also brought
in jury trials and local elected
assemblies and so he sort of late some
of the foundations for a reform
he wanted to bring in a constitution
which was really the last proper chance
to bring it in but he was assassinated
the day he was going to bring in that
Constitution but as for the love life
that's another thing altogether well let
me ask you first where did you find the
love letters well the love letters are
in the Russian archives in Moscow but
there's an interesting story there
because these love letters have never
really been worked on by any historians
before and that's because they've only
recently returned to the Russian
archives and this is how it happened
when alexander ii was assassinated his
widow his mistress who'd become his wife
princess Katia left Russia went to live
in Paris and she took most to this huge
correspondent 3,000 outrageous letters
with her to Paris where they remained at
private hands until 1998 and in 1998 the
Rothschild banking family bought these
letters why because in 1945 the Red Army
had captured when they took Berlin and
Vienna had captured the Rothschild
banking archives and they took them back
to Moscow and they wanted to swap and
the Russians agreed so the Rothschilds
got their banking archives which aren't
very interesting I'm sure but Moscow got
these letters and last we could work on
them all and they're love letters
between a 40-something year old Emperor
Alex on a second and his young
schoolgirl 18-year old mistress which
when they met and they started their
affair they're passionate they're
poignant they're increasingly political
and they're highly uninhibited and
sexual and in fact the stuff in these
letters that I didn't even know was
invented in the 1870s I thought it had
only just been invented in the 21st
century but you'll have to read them to
see what I'm referring to them so this
article that you wrote doesn't have all
the racy stuff in it it doesn't have all
the racy stuff in it because because
some of it is very racy even by even by
the standards of 2016 how long was
Alexander the second the Emperor but he
was a he was a firm 1855 to 1881 and how
was he assassinated well it was it was a
tragedy
he brought in reform he believed in
reform he'd negotiated this complex
emancipation of the serfs so he'd shown
real political skill but he raised
expectations in the 1860s for for a
reform of autocracy which he was not
willing to fulfill this caused a
backlash that led to a terrorist
movement demanding the destruction of
autocracy altogether and these
terrorists hunted him like a wild animal
they threw bombs at him they fired guns
at him in fact he believed because his
mistress capture was there on the day of
the first assassination attempt he
believed she was his guardian angel and
there were six attempts to kill him but
she couldn't save him when it came to
1881 after they'd been together for all
these years
that the bomb was thrown at his carriage
he he was fine the carriage was was
smashed but he got out and he inspected
the dead and wounded it and his God said
please get back in the carriage please
let's get you out of here he said no I
want to inspect you know this wounded
man that's what I do I'm an emperor and
there was one more terrorist one more
killer and they just threw the bomb
right at his feet and blew his legs to
smithereens he was taken back to the
Winter Palace where he died on his couch
and one of the people who saw and I was
a little boy who became nicholas ii his
grandson in reading your book and i just
kept asking how does this man remember
all this I I mean I probably could get
in here and find somewhere a statistic
you wouldn't remember but he would be
bad what do you what technique do you
use in order to put all this together
and and what I want you to eventually
get into how many Romanovs there weren't
all that yeah well I mean writing these
books is a huge challenge and is a
nightmare and for some reason I have a
taste for doing these vast subjects like
Jerusalem over 5,000 years this is only
about 400 years but it's 20 minutes 20
or 21 Romanoff Prince princes or czars
and Czarina's Empress's and Empress
Empress and it covers so many years so
you can imagine every single monarch in
this book has their children there
their mistresses their ministers their
field marshals they're great poets and
composers and all of this has to be
mastered so writing these books is a
hell of a mental challenge I have to say
and I you know I literally immerse
myself in the subject for the few years
that I'm doing and I only read about
this subject and obviously afterwards I
can't wait to read some sort of James
Ellroy thrillers or something you know
the day I finish I start reading sort of
John the Caray or James Ellroy or
something like that but during it I
concentrate absolutely on it and I just
work my way from the beginning rain by
rain and with each one I read all the
books on the subject first of all I get
all the the the books and journals
articles that have been published in
Russia and then ultimately I go to
Russia and walk around the palaces look
at the archives and then when I feel
I've got enough I move on to the next to
the next
Manik you were here last in 2004 and we
also did an interview Peter splendid in
in London in 2013 I want to just put up
on the screen the number of nonfiction
books you've written so that the
audience can know you know the kind of
thing you've been involved in we go back
to the first one in 2001 Katherine and
the great castle integrate and Potemkin
yes Stalin the court of the Czar which
we talked about in 2003 did young Stalin
2007 Jerusalem the biography in 2011 and
we say the Romanovs you say Romano's
well I mean doesn't matter but it yeah
yeah I say both a I mean the Russians to
say Romanov you know but um but we
English say Romanoff and we say Potemkin
but they say Potomac it you know doesn't
matter
I'm what you mentioned Rothschild the
name rot I want to quote back to you
this is a 2008 Vanity Fair article that
undoubtedly you remember in which a
friend of yours the Honorable Hanna
Rothschild who is she she's she's um
she's a she's a novelist and writer and
she's head of the British the the
British Museum although she's a very
important woman in England and she's a
daughter of Laurel
child and he's a great person here's the
quote though yeah he is the best lunch
date in London his gossip is so clever
ranging through centuries and across all
sections of society did you find that to
be a compliment I don't know what do you
think I'm not sure I'm not sure if that
is a compliment but she's a great person
so you know she can get away with saying
this stuff
are you a gossip well you know I think
all human affairs all human business or
politics is is about human relationships
you can call that gossip if you like I'm
not terribly interested in in gossip
that has no importance on the world on
the world stage but if you look at these
books for example in all of them I
they are studies of power and how power
works its effect on personality and the
effect of personalities on power I think
the interesting thing is that even if
you're whether you're talking about an
imperial court with flunkies and you
know and Chamberlain's and and
ladies-in-waiting or whether you're
talking about the Office of the
President of the United States or the
Prime Minister of England elected
officials power works in a similar way
and it emanates from the person who's
been elected who has the power whether
it's a bomber or Putin and I'm a student
the way that works and I'm fascinated by
the way that that happens so I'm hoping
that this book I mean you can read it as
an entertainment about a lot of shocking
murders and and the rest you can look at
it as an explanation about how Russia
works today well you could just look
upon it as a study of human nature and
power and you can call that gossip but
really it repeatedly shows I've just
given you an example you know in 1881
when alexander ii was was murdered his
personality was essential to reform
going ahead when he was assassinated
reform really ended in russia until 1917
so personality again and again and again
in russian history just as in american
history you know look at Putin look at
look at Trump look at you know look at
the Clintons again and again personality
is decisive in power and in politics and
so my books concentrate on the personal
your favorite personality not your
favorite leader but the one that you had
the most fun researching well Peter the
grade is just you know is just totally
compelling and you know he's a
misunderstood character and I wanted to
look at him in a very political sense as
well as a colorful character well when
was he the Emperor well he was Emperor
until seventeen seventeen seventy
twenty-five he died and he'd been there
since 1682 since he was a child so an
incredibly long reign right even I find
kind of breathtaking with these people
you look at you look at some of the two
of the greatest men in this book Peter
the Great and Prince Potemkin who was
Catherine the Great's partner Minister
probably her secret husband they had two
of the most talented individuals in the
whole Romanov story and yet both of them
died at 52 now I'm 50 so that's a pretty
terrifying sisters that now there's a
statistic that I remember and that is on
my mind the moment because think of all
they achieved in their years and they
died at 52 both of them utterly
exhausted by the way what did they
achieve why did Peter would start with
Peter the Great and why was he called
the great well he was called the great
because he achieved so much he
modernized Russia he brought in modern
military modern artillery modern
technology Western experts Western forms
of government and he modernized the
military ters extent that they could
defeat the greatest military power in
Europe of their day Sweden he founded
some Petersburg a new northern capital
modern city of Venice of the north he
conquered the Baltic and he created the
blacks of the Baltic Fleet the Baltic
Fleet which made Russia a naval power of
the first time and he did all of this
really through the force of his
personality and despite all the rational
reasons and the wonderful Swedish
methods of government of the German
titles he brought in at court and and
the modern artillery that he developed
for them for the military and these
wonderful ships of the line for his
Russian Navy despite all of this modern
stuff
he was always basically and
autocrat who ruled wherever he was was
the government whatever he said was the
government if he slept the government
slept when he was drunk the government
was drunk he was everything and he was
the ultimate personal ruler of Russia he
was a genius but he was also a monster
you know he took took part in the four
headings of his of his enemies he
tortured his own son to death he you
know he was fascinated with the human
body dismantling it
I remember after when he was in when he
was in Holland and he attended all these
dissections his medical dissections he
was fascinated the human body
afterwards he queued up and he said can
I bite the body I want to see how the
dead body feels in your teeth and then
he made his entire entourage do the same
and after that he bought a he bought his
own collection of surgical tools and
some of his entourage had a sawtooth he
insisted on pulling it out himself
another one had a bad foot off went the
foot so after that if you had a if you
had a sore arm or a bad tooth or a sore
ear and you were in Peter the Great's
entourage you made it you made sure you
never mentioned it how many different
you say 21 or son but how many different
Emperor's did you write about I think
there are 20 that are actually that
actually ruled but there are also many
Regents many prime ministers many field
marshals there are many characters there
are many artists I mean this book has
everyone from Tchaikovsky and Pushkin
Dostoevsky and it has you know many many
fascinating and talented people from
Potemkin a1 you know who's probably the
most talented Minister that the Romanovs
ever had Taurus Putin who was probably
one of the least talented and he's
politically least talented advisors the
Romanovs ever had we talked about
Rasputin for a minute or you go into
great detail about him when did he first
pop up and in the Russian society when
he first popped up in 1905 and it's
interesting well I think the sort of
analysis of him in the past has been
slightly skewed for different ways too
much emphasis on whether he's a healer
or not on the haemophilia of
of czarevitch Alexei and what's much
more important I think is that he
represented he represented what Nicholas
Alexandra felt was the authentic
foundation of the Romanov autocracy
which was the relationship between the
Tsar and the peasantry sitting with re
sitting in the who's standing behind him
no I don't recognize them but there he
is unmistakable Rasputin who was the
first emperor he had contact with well
Nicholas Nicholas the second all only
Nicholas started with nickel again and
what was his relationship with Nicholas
to sell wife well there was no love
affair these are great pictures there's
no love of that there was no love affair
as was rumored with Alexandra but
Alexandra and Nicholas both absolutely
needed rest Boonton first of all there
was the healing of the haemophiliac
child a tragic story a tragic family
story and the parents were agonized by
this by this by the child's suffering by
his his pain as he'd almost died
repeatedly from haemophiliac attacks but
also by the immense stress they placed
on themselves by insisting that he must
succeed to the full plenitude of
autocracy and that the and that the
disease had to be a total secret so
displaced enormous stress on the child
and on themselves and what year's
nicholas ii him well night this is 1905
you know 19 1904 is when the child
Alexei was born they meet Rasputin a
1905 the next year and he remains
absolutely key to them right up until
his murder in 1916 in December 1916 I
guess I didn't a serrated the nicholas
ii was the emperor for how long
Oh over 20 years over 20 years 1894 to
1917 and the reason I wanted to talk
about brass unique this is the end of
the Romanovs this is the end we've
started it was sort of starting at the
end but it's some I mean it's an
interesting sitting you asked about
Rasputin because Rasputin became
essential to that to the parents as well
as the child but he didn't really become
totally politically important than
essential until World War one
and in World War one in 1915 Nicholas
decided to become supreme commander in
chief of the army and he left the
capital in the charge of the Empress
Alexandra now the a pathetic stoner was
extremely prudish woman extremely
self-righteous religious who believed
absolutely in sacred autocracy as a
system and a complete disdain for
democracy and can I interrupt to ask you
define the word autocracy which is just
the rule of one man but sacred autocracy
that is the Romanoff ideology that
Russia could only be ruled by one man
the Czar of the legitimate god-given
god-blessed Romanov dynasty and and when
when Nicholas a second left Alexandra in
complete command of politics back back
back in in in Petersburg or Petrograd it
was then renamed she found herself in
this preposterous situation having had
for over 20 years complete contempt for
all politics and high society and
politicians particularly journalists she
suddenly found herself in the business
of politics and she knew nobody so she
had to turn this self-righteous very
prudish woman had to turn to the one
person who she felt might know some
people in Petersburg and that was
Rasputin who only knew the most
incompetent corrupt and depraved people
in some Petersburg
so irony of ironies the people he sent
her and suggested as minister to her
were the most depraved and incompetent
people in in some piece Berg and this
was a catastrophe
and this book is based on many
correspondences between between czars
and and a private correspondence there's
several thousand letters between Nicolas
and Alexander at that time apart from
being fascinating because you know
they're very sexually passionate about
each other they're very close there
they'll it also reveals how isolated
they were isolated by their own wishes
by the way and how much they depended to
the no third degree on Rasputin and when
you read Alexander as loud as you
realize that she was close to being
insane she was unbalanced I mean the
letters when you if you if you
when you read the book I think people
will be amazed just how just how
unstable she was and she'd be sending
Nicholas things like rasputin's comb to
brush his hair before he met ministers
say he'd be blessed and protected things
like this so you realize that that the
prestige and the power of the monarchy
is seeping away fast when she's in
charge who didn't like rescue well no
one like Rasputin except for the
imperial family of which there were
children the door to the four daughters
and the son and the Imperial couple and
by the by the time by World War one
started in 1914 no one like Rasputin but
people just couldn't face the fact that
the responsibility for the misrule in
Russia belonged to the Tsar and czarina
particularly the Tsar and they blamed it
on Rasputin they were sure that if they
killed Rasputin they would solve the
problem of Russia's misrule how did they
do it I I mean if you go to st.
Petersburg and a lot of Americans do
where would they find Nicholas and
Alexandra living at that time and wordid
Rasputin live well
[ __ ] Alexandra lived outside some
Petersburg they hated some Pittsburgh
they regarded as a cesspit of immoral
immoral debauchery and they lived out
its ASCO Salo which was a suburban
palace and they lived in the Alexander
Palace the palace built by Catherine the
Great for her grandson Alexander the
first bazaar of war and peace we might
come to him later but what was the
Winter Palace the winner's palace is
right in the center of some Petersburg
now Rasputin lived in a flat in the city
and when he came out to see the Zorn's
arena it's asked herself he would meet
in as he would meet them in a small
cottage outside the city gates that no
one knew about that belonged to a friend
of theirs and that little house is still
there by the way and no one goes to see
it but they should because that was
where Russia was in a way governed and
it's just outside the gates they had
come out because all the police and so
on controlled by the Minister of the
Interior will would make a record of
anyone visiting but anyway this way they
avoid anyone knowing but of course
everybody knew anyway
and meanwhile also in the city the the
use of pot palace which I'm sure many
American tourists will visit and that
has the room whereas Putin was killed in
the courtyard when he was killed
and Prince Yusupov was the wealthiest
man in Russia he was at cross-dressing
bisexual opium addict an interesting
character who'd been at Oxford
University of course and him and his
friend
grandi Dimitri was a member of the
imperial family of both members of the
imperial family in fact and they decided
that the only way to save Russia and
save the monarchy was to kill Rasputin
they were mantis eyes the killing of
Rasputin in the ways that we all know so
that kind of Rasputin was kind of poison
but he got up again he was shot but he
got up again you know Virge like a
vampire movie you know he was hurt they
virtually claim this that suck a stake
in his heart and that finally killed him
but in fact the murder was very
different from that and there were
interesting things about it one is we
now know there was some sort of British
involvement the British Secret Service
the early version of mi6 was involved
somehow in plotting against Rasputin and
may have actually been involved in the
assassination why not well
Rasputin was widely believed first of
all to be against the war which was true
and that was I said that was established
the only sensible policy or one of the
few sensible things he did devised was
stay out of the war but that was a very
difficult thing to do to stay out of the
war it wasn't a something a Nicholas a
second was really strong enough to
withstand the pressure to go into the
war who's which side was Russia and
Russia was on the Allied side the
American side the British side the
French side so so they decided that they
decide the British were interested in
him being killed once to keep to keep
Russia in the war and to save the
monarchy without the monarchy Russia
would in any case probably leave the war
and many people believe that the
monarchy would be destroyed if Rasputin
continued his his his dark influence so
somehow British agents who were friends
with Yusupov were involved in this plot
and what really happened was they led
him to this house
they shot him once the bullet didn't
kill him he ran outside and somebody
from behind fired at him and brought him
down with a second shot that was not
fatal and this is the interesting bit at
this point someone walked up with a huge
piste like a sort of Clint Eastwood
style Magnum and they put it right
against Rasputin's for Adhir point-blank
and just blew him away like that you
know it was it was not this kind of
romantic sort of gothic understory that
we see in sort of Hollywood movies it
was more like just the cold-blooded
execution of a peasant here's the famous
picture of Rasputin on the screen yeah
what effect did this had won and what
exact year was he killed December 16 but
you can see that this is a great picture
this is where he's he's actually they've
dug that they found the body underneath
the ice in the other Navy River to him
and they're a thrill under the ice and
took a while to find him and what's
interesting is you know he's thawing
there before his autopsy but you can see
that the the point-blank shot to the
middle of the forehead
he's an execution shot and there you can
see it pretty clearly so what impact did
it had that they killed him
well the funny thing was he didn't have
the impact anyone expected it instead of
strengthening the monarchy it exposed
and emasculated the monarchy because it
revealed that nothing changed when
Rasputin died nicholas ii was still the
same nicholas ii ruling with alexander
before he didn't suddenly start
reforming the country or giving in to a
constitutional government or giving in
to a representative government nothing
changed all it showed was that the
government was Hollow and that nicholas
ii was a deeply incompetent ruler i'm at
the end for a couple reasons one
necklace and Alexander's assassination
and and the fact that the Bolsheviks
took over in seventeen I want you to
kind of lead us up to that and explain
after this assassination of Rasputin
when did when did the next step in this
process well I mean what was in December
1916 and when the monarchy literally
lasted two months afterwards
and the irony was that you know this
this wasn't a revolution led by Lenin
and Stalin and Trotsky they were all in
exile or in Siberia in fact Lenin had
said just weeks before he said you know
we've missed it this revolution is never
going to happen in my lifetime but but
here it came it was totally unexpected
and yet easily predictable because
people started to protest about food
shortages in the capital and it's
quickly spread the the troops who are in
the city started to fraternize with with
the rebels and Nikolas was far away at
the front and he tried to hit one was he
well he was right at the tree was right
at the front at the headquarters and it
took him a long time to get back and he
was he was foolish to try to get back in
a rush because his train got stuck you
know got sidelined supposedly stopped by
workers and he found himself totally
alone in a railway station in the middle
of nowhere and he had to ask his
generals what to do and the general said
as one abdicate and so suddenly he was
alone in this in his imperial carriage
and he had to sign an abdication so
first of all he abdicated to his son
Alexei bazzara vich the haemophiliac boy
now in his teens and then he spoke to
his doctor and he said just tell me
something
is this haemophilia curable the doctor
said no he said is it you know how long
could he live he said well he couldn't
live a long time and he could die at 30
you could die very young and then and
then he sort of said you know what I've
decided I need to change changed my plan
I'm going to change my abdication I'm
gonna leave the throne to my brother
Michael and keep this to keep a child
with me it was his decision any Emperor
could say this is where it's going next
well that's a good question actually
that's it that's a very uncertain
question one of the great themes of this
book and a rush of modern Russian
history and if we look at Putin is
succession the succession in any
government is a measure of its
orderliness it's it's of its authority
of its system if you like and you know
up until tsar paul the first in 1796 any
Tsar could just a point anyway
who the hell they liked as their
successor so Peter the great successor
was his wife Catherine the first one of
the more extraordinary colorful female
characters in this book now she a great
she was careful yeah yeah Catherine the
first but she was little better than a
sort of camp follower she'd first
appeared in walking naked as a prisoner
into the Russian camp she was neither a
Russian Naughton Orthodox nor noble and
yet Peter the Great married her and made
her renamed her Catherine and crowned
her Empress of Russia when he died she
was chosen as his successor even though
she had no claim to the throne so in
Russia the state can make the state can
break someone that that's the power of
autocracy so so up until then you know
desires could choose their own successes
but in up to 1796 no more the irony is
that in in nowadays if since the 1990s
and in 2016 the presidents of Russia who
are again autocrats can choose their own
successes again in a way that is
unthinkable really in the 21st century
so you have President Putin was named by
Yeltsin as success success of the
election was it was was could've fixed
and similarly you know Putin chose
Medvedev Medvedev chose Putin again
normally so once again we're in a
situation in Russia where despite all
the trappings of democracy in the facade
of democracy again the Tsar can choose
his own successor but go back to why it
made the whole revolution in 1917
yeah and what happened to the last
Romanov sin yes well that's just a
terrible story by the way I'm I I don't
take the usual romantic approach to
Nicholas in Alexandria that is the
traditional the movie view I don't take
it and I and I differ from the sort of
traditional romantic approach they were
a couple who were in love with each
other they were loving parents but they
were also rulers and I think when people
read in this book what they were really
like
I think people be amazed about how
rapidly anti-semitic they were for
example you know there's the stuff about
Jews is pretty shocking considering that
they're regarded as one of
romantic heroes Nicholas and Alexandra
next to you in your family well it
connects to me my family because we we
left Russia at that time my mother's
family to escape them but also you know
you know that that kind of knickers and
eggs and was kind of vindictiveness
their duplicity I mean I think people
will be surprised when they read the
book that you know that they may not
recognize a Nicholas and Alexandra that
they thought they knew and the family is
only one part of it but I will say that
when they were overthrown in in in
February 1919 seventeen they did conduct
themselves with immense grace in facing
fear humiliation of being prisoners of a
Republican government of a provisional
government and they then behaved with
immense dignity and that's why they've
been made into Saints by the Russian
Orthodox Church but at the same time as
as it's worth remembering that at the
same time as Nicholas a second now
abdicated now depos was reading Tolstoy
and books to his children and in
captivity he was also reading his
children the the protocols of the Elders
of Zion the the rapidly anti-semitic
forgery so that made this gives us a
little bit of perspective but you know
in the end when the Bolsheviks took
power in October 1917 and Lenin Stalin
told Trotsky you know this was a totally
new turn of event suddenly they were in
danger of their lives and it was
unthinkable that the children could be
in danger of their lives - but Lenin and
Trotsky and Stein were ruthless ruthless
operatives and they could take no
chances it's clear when you look at it
that the orders to kill them all
including the children came from the top
came from Lenin even though that in was
far too clever to leave a written order
he was very aware of history but when it
came to kill them to kill all of them
these these four gorgeous young
daughters the the innocent son as well
as the parents as well as the family
doctor and the entourage that was now
never has an as a murder have been so
bungled never has a crime been so
if it was possible to make it more
appalling and more atrocious they did it
by sheer incompetence and where were
they I mean the scene where they were
they are in a house in Ekaterinburg the
Apache half house which had been renamed
the house a special-purpose very
sinister normally name for the house and
they were kept there all the windows
were painted white and the family were
sort of kept in total isolation
different members of their entourage
were taken away mysteriously and then
shot in the woods and granted they
realized that something terrible was
going to happen and yet the white armies
the armies opposed the revolution were
approaching and they could hear the guns
at night and the order came from Moscow
to the Ekaterinburg to the Urals Soviet
that if the whites got too near they
would they could wipe out the whole
family and so this job was done they
were woken up at about 1:00 in the
morning they came downstairs putting on
their clothes they were taken into one
room a cellar room thought they were
being moved although being moved they
came down little boy sat down he'd
recently had a hemophiliac attack
princess Empress Alexandra asked for a
seat she sat down Nikolas stood in front
of the boy seemingly protective and
suddenly these sort of 12
ruff-ruff Ian's came in with with guns
and you know bayonets and pistols and
rifles and half of them were drunk some
of them were psychopaths who'd murdered
people before one of them and beheaded a
man during a bank robbery before the
Revolution and they came in and they
read a sentence of death and then they
all started firing but it all went wrong
immediately because everyone was
supposed to kill one person but of
course a lot of them weren't comfortable
shooting girls so they they aimed at the
person they were meant to shoot and then
they suddenly switched their gun and
shot at Nikolas the second in the chest
so he was killed instantly but everyone
else was screaming and all of them were
alive still and then there was this kind
of free-for-all of shooting a fusillade
off diffusal a killing some of them but
tragically all the girls and all the
children basically were wearing
bizarre bulletproof vests not
bulletproof vests but vests sewn with
the Romanoff diamonds hundreds and
hundreds of diamonds have been sewn into
that underwear so they could have money
in case they escaped in case they needed
to buy their way out and they'd spent
months sewing these diamonds in you know
can you imagine they had billions that
equivalent of billions of pounds on
their bodies and they weighed of what
they weighed an enormous amount but when
the bullets came tragically these these
made their their execution and their
agony much much longer because the
bullets bounced off diamonds the hardest
substance known to man and they didn't
die so then they had to go could go in
among the bodies the floor as they said
like there's too much blood on the floor
it was as slippery as an ice rink and
they had to walk in and stab them and
shoot them in the head and still two of
the girls at the end of all this after
end of like half an hour of mayhem
terrible mayhem two of the girls were
still sort of coughing and awake and had
to be stabbed and shot all over again I
mean writing it I I must admit I sort of
wept when I when I was when I was
writing this scene it's agony exactly
how did who report it on what happened
in because you as I remember you talked
about being in a room with those dim
light bulb and you can't see each other
and all that and but who had the
information well the interesting thing
is that all the well several of the of
the assassins of the murderers wrote
proudly wrote memoirs about what they'd
what they're done and because the whole
thing was such dick Butler and because
it took literally three days and three
nights without sleep to actually bury
the bodies because what happened the
bodies are afterwards which I don't we
should go into now is so but it's you
know involved sulfuric acid and fire and
petrol and fire and I mean and being
buried in different places and terrible
things being done to the bodies of the
girls specially and niccola's that that
when they came to write their memoirs
they were so confused about what had
happened in this kind of three-day
sleepless three-day struggle to sort of
disposed opposed of the bodies that they
they contradicted themselves in
different places there are different
of the story and all of these were kept
in the archives and these is this new
information that you found not all about
know when there are new there are new
aspects of it yeah but but the story is
still going on which is so interesting
because as everyone knows the bodies
were found in the 90s and buried in 1998
Boris Yeltsin super presiding and they
were buried in the in the in the family
vault in the Peter and Paul Fortress and
it's in Petersburg but but two of the
bodies were missing not alice starseer
who did not survive but grand duchess
maria her sister and the Tsarevich
Alexei and their bodies were never found
and then ten years later in 2007 so very
recently they found the remains of those
two bodies just just bits of skeleton
and they were tested by Western
specialists and found to be the Romanovs
the missing Romanovs but the Orthodox
Church backed as always by the President
of the Russian Federation because in
Russia the Orthodox Church is really a
branch of the autocracy challenged these
findings and so for ten years nothing
was done with these body parts then last
year were right up to date now last year
President Putin his security agents
agencies and the church suddenly decided
they would test everything again they
exhumed Nicholas the second temporarily
tested his body
they've exhumed the children and they've
tested these two last bodies and at the
time of the time we was speaking
nothing's been announced yet but I think
this has something to do with Putin's
view of history Putin's preparation for
the centenary 1917 and 1918 the sin
tinea which is coming up next year after
so something is up with this I don't
know what it is but we're right there
now so that the room on the Romanoff's
in some in some sense if this story is
happening right now as we speak in
Russia something's about to happen and
it reflects president Putin's view of
history and his view was very
interesting he he is without ideology he
regards the two worst czars of Russia
as gorbachev and nicholas ii for example
one is extra viet leader one is a Roman
officer he regards Lenin as a disaster
for Russia but he regards Stalin as a
hugely successful statesman he regards
Peter the great Alexander the first
Nicholas the first is great Catherine
the Great and Potemkin as great Russian
statesman the new gods nicholas ii as a
useless flop who betrayed the country by
abdicating and he regards gorbachev our
great hero who we god was to serve as
such an impressive liberal modernized
that he regards him as a disaster too so
he sees the Empress of Russia a
politically by he judged them by their
success and he sees himself President
Putin as a Russian leader especially to
the Russian world to be judged with the
great rulers of Russian history go back
to comment about anti-semitism yeah and
your own family and all that I think I
read in your but Lenin and Trotsky who
were on either side of Stalin at one
point
oh poor Jewish no Lenin wasn't Jewish
not at all no Jewish some Jewish some
Jewish some Jewish or something like
1/16 Jewish or something he was um he
was basically rushed and he also had was
part tartar stalin was georgian and
Trotsky was Jewish the reason I ask you
that is because it throughout your book
there is a lot of anti-semitism down in
the years what's that what's the basis
of that well this is the strange thing
is that you know the Romanoff's net
anti-semitism become a family fetish
that made no sense for them whatsoever
and if this goes was a wider wider
crisis that in the monarchy that they
had which was that you know they
couldn't quite decide if they wanted to
be emperor of this huge multinational
multi religion empire with all these
different religions and faiths the fins
that poles the Jews that George's the
Armenians and so on the Tartars who were
Muslim
or if they wanted to be Russian Czars
nationalistic czars of the sort of the
SMAW of the Slavs at
this is a kind of one of the kind of
contradictions that they couldn't quite
work out and in the end from nipples the
first onwards they basically plumped for
being nationalists Russian rulers and
they gradually and incredibly foolishly
alienated all of their minorities none
more so than the poles the Georgians and
the Jews which is why so many of those
peoples became Bolsheviks and Mensheviks
and revolutionaries and terrorists but
they did it completely it was it was a
completely absurd concept they regarded
the jews nicholas ii used to say the
British the British 'men is a year by
which he meant that the English and the
Jews were the same they they believed in
all the things that were wrong with the
modern world newspapers the stock
exchange democracy everything that
nicholas ii hated and he regularly
talked about jews once he said once she
said someone said in what what is what's
a newspaper what do you think happens in
a newspaper and he said a newspapers
just a bunch of jews trying to make
everyone go to war with each other
so he was rapidly and it there's a great
scene when he goes and stays with his
cousins in england he goes the state of
their of the seventh of Sandringham and
out of the seventh was incredibly
pro-jewish and friends with the
Rothschilds and other big Jewish
families and he had one of these big
Jewish tycoons saying that Baron Hirsch
who was the wealthiest man in Europe at
the time and he deliberately had him to
sort of try and introduce him to
Nicholas the second to make a more Pro
Jewish and Nicholas a second was
horrified and he wrote to his mother he
said they've got a lot of Jewish horse
dealers staying here and I'm so
horrified that I think I'm just going to
but not gonna say a word the whole
weekend so that's what he did I want to
put the list of your books back up on
the screen they've all those books which
once all the best
I think Stalin the court the Reds are in
Jerusalem of the two that have sold the
past I mean there are now in many many
language I think they're at forty five
languages now something but from your
standpoint what's the thread through all
these books
well the thread is simple to read just
these are books that I would longed to
write and I passionately wanted to write
I
to produce books on these subjects that
were based on scholarship based on new
archives and yet whirring what working
were readable by everybody accessible so
if we saw you in an archive where would
that archive be physically well it would
either be in a kind of format Palace in
in Moscow or in or in the archives at
the Soviet archives which is a special
building 1920s building and in Moscow or
I might be walking around us I might be
walking around the palace trying to work
out you know where people wear which
actual rooms they actually lived in or
if it was Jerusalem I might be walking
around the city tumbler going down the
tunnels trying to understand how
different layers of the city were built
on top of each other last time you were
here do that before we talk to you about
the archives and you had been in the
archives of course for this dawn book
there was some inference at that time
that the archives are going to be closed
what's happened from 2004 to now in
Russia with archives well that's been a
huge sort of tightening of there's been
a huge tightening of access to the
archives it's much harder to work on
them now especially the modern ones I
mean they don't care so much about the
Romanoff archives to be honest but the
Stalin archives and any political
archives if they're not open or if they
haven't already been shown totally to
the public they're not going to open now
probably and you know there's a real
there's a real dark atmosphere in Russia
at the moment and this is part of an
anti-western as in a phobic atmosphere
and working in his archives was never
easy believe you me and I think I
remember the first time I started
working on Catherine the Great and
Potemkin archives the archivists would
determine that I wouldn't find anything
and when I started working sitting
underneath the gallery in this archive
looking at the documents for the first
time the archivist who tried to stop me
went upstairs and as I leant over the
papers there was a squealing sound and
something landed on my head and it was a
kitten can I looked up at the I looked
up at the archivist and she just was
leaning over there and she just waved at
me like that
she was just letting me know that I
wasn't that welcome with the archives
how many hours how many days have you
spent in those archives over there
I've spent I've spent months over there
in those archives and but also like I
mean walking around places is also
hugely important you know in writing
these books because so often like when I
was writing about Catherine the Great
and Potemkin you know Potemkin villages
and villages that the villages that a
fake that have never been built and book
after book just said he never built
anything it was all a fake and when I
went down to the south to Crimea to
Ukraine to to Sebastopol and so on I
found many of these um you know many of
these places had been built by him and
they're still there anyway I mean we're
before we talked about you'd been to all
15 homes of yeah have you been to all
the homes of all the Romanovs yeah
pretty much
how many Oh least 15 palaces probably
more you know there are so many of them
because every grand do you cut there at
that palace I haven't been to every
single one but far from it there were
thousands of them probably I mean if you
include all the hunting lodge not
thousands but probably there probably up
to a hundred residences where people @gn
yeah they let you they'd let us then do
you have to have a translator with you
or can you now speak good Russian now my
Russian is still a work in progress but
but you know without it you couldn't do
any of this work and you know you you
can get into all these places and and as
for the letters themselves you know
Dario made some of them in Russian but
many of them were in English I mean one
of the one of the things that may
surprise people is that you know
everyone hated Alek pampers a legs and
rehearse the German but actually she was
really English she was brought up by
Queen Victoria and she wrote you know
her letters between Nicholas and
Alexandra the love letters are all in
English a very broken English but in
English in English you know time is
running out and yeah this this has
nothing to do with these books but it
does have something to do with you I
want to show your wife who's written how
many novels by now Oh at least 15 and
you two live in Kensington and in London
we do and you've got fairly high social
presence over there I mean quickly we've
just written our first book together oh
yeah a children's book that is um that
is coming out in October
make sure your better
half at the moment he is named Santa
she's a lot better-looking than I am I
can tell she here she is my name is
Santa Monti fury I live in London here
this is my garden in Kensington - I live
with my husband finally buy one Tiffany
and my two children Lily who is six and
fashioned my son who is full I always
wanted right I always did right as a
child I wrote little books for children
friends of my parents and then when I
got to school I started writing short
stories for my girlfriend and then a
friend of my mother's once made one and
she was right so I followed the formula
and I made one by return of post it was
sent back to me rejection of course and
that was the starting offer projections
and I think being a writer you just have
to swallow the rejection put them in a
bottom drawer
and continue that's hilarious you two
have been married for you ever seen that
no I've never seen that but you'll
noticed when she's leading there in our
library she's it's quite funny because
she's talking about all her lovely books
that she's written and she's leaning on
Stalin's complete works just behind her
if you look carefully how long have you
been married
oh go on a long time we married in 1998
how does it work with the two of you
both writing books all the time
do you know originally we actually
worked at the same table when we started
writing we didn't have any hope that
we'd be successful so we had a very
small apartment not in Kensington and we
had one table which was also a
dining-room table and our desk and we
worked at different sides of it and we
spent our whole time arguing about what
kind of music to listen to because she
wanted to listen to sort of Celine Dion
all the time which of course I could not
tolerate well I wanted to listen to sort
of Guns and Roses or David Bowie or
FlowRider or you know or pitbull all
sort of loud driving music which helped
me keep up my narrative Drive in these
in these long books so we all get a lot
of bat music real argued mainly about
music but now we have our own offices in
our house at different ends of the house
so she can listen to all the silly in
deal and she likes as you know we
haven't even
we got to talk about this book there's
so much more in here and there's one
thing I wanted to bring up because it
just stupefied me as I'm reading it the
dwarfs the tools what stole I mean tell
us how often did these Emperor's I don't
know what you'd call it play with the
doors
well the dwarfs are kind of carry a lot
of reviewers have have said that this
book reads makes makes the game of
Thrones look like it look like a vicars
tea party I think one of them said in
the Financial Times
you know the dwarfs what kind of key
they partly signified the kind of
exceptionalism the Sir exceptional
sanctity or bizarre they wanted people
around them who they had a lot of
cripples around them a lot of freaks a
lot of fools and they had dwarfs and the
doors were often like their favorite
people but Peter the great love to have
Dwarfs weddings he had Giants weddings
the Empress Anna was really a character
out of Game of Thrones she was a cruel
horrible sultry such a vindictive woman
and she had an entourage of women who
were lacking limbs so one was called the
legless one was called the armless one
she also had fools she made princes into
into fools and they had to when she came
out of church they had to sit on eggs
just as chickens and cluck then she had
a she had another fool who she said
should get married
and so the fool invited to his house
where he was in bed with a lactating
goat who he said was his new wife and
she loved that and worst of all she
loved dwarf-tossing and Dwarfs to have
fights where they pulled each other's
hair and if they refused to fight or
refused to be tossed they were beaten
but if they did what she said she would
spoil them with new clothes and food and
big cash gifts so that some of them
became incredibly rich and by the end of
by the end of the sort of 1740s but it
was an extraordinary story I mean this
is it this is an amazing sort of family
story if you think about it where morphs
are tossed
terrible cruelty czar perpetrate if the
Empire is increased there are great love
affairs but it's also a family where
fathers kill their sons where wives have
husbands overthrown and murdered we're
sons collude in the murder of fathers
houses this is a there's a family unlike
any other how many of the 20 Roman after
you write about were assassinated or
killed well of the last twelve six were
murdered violently or either
assassinated or murdered so that gives
you an idea so from this sort of from
the late eighteenth century onwards half
of them were killed so I guess one of
the themes of the book is Russia's a
very hard country to rule and to be czar
is a very hard thing to be should
President Putin be called czar Putin he
should be because he's really the Tsar
now people say you know is he rich is he
corrupt you know there were a lot of
these stories but Russians especially
powerful Russians that I know just
laughed about this about this very
question they said for him wealth is
irrelevant
he's the Tsar everything belongs to him
who did who tried the most to get a
democracy over there well I think
alexander ii is the most kind of
sympathetic of the family as i said i
read a you know of Gorbachev and Yeltsin
Yeltsin is a hugely underrated character
I mean he was a flawed flawed great but
flawed I mean he was a drunk he went to
war in Chechnya and terrible things were
done there but he opened up Russia he
tried to correct abuses he opened up
history he brought in democracy you say
he brought in Putin what did he think
Putin would do well the trouble with the
Russian this is the sixth case but the
succession thing we were talking about
earlier is that it's impossible for an
autocrat for his art to retire without
being murdered and in our own period
it's impossible for a president to
retire without agreement that he in his
entire entourage and family will not be
prosecuted for either war crimes or for
vast corruption and that means that in
effect it's virtually impossible for any
president to retire that's why when
Yeltsin did retire he made a deal with
his successor and that's why Putin can
never really retire and he was asked by
the way by his aunt washing will you
ever give up
you ever retire and he said I could I'll
never retire I will never be like
Gorbachev or Nicholas the second and
leave the country to chaos to scum to
hooligans he said they were weak czars
they were betrayers and I will never
abdicate a one of those that have joined
us to know that in our c-span archive
they can find another three hours of you
talking about Stalin and Jerusalem and
other things and this book the Romanovs
knew in the year 2016
what's next I'm gonna write I've written
two novels set in Sandton and set in
Russia in the 20th century their love
stories and that sort of thrillers and
love stories and I'm just writing the
third of the trilogy and then I'll have
done the trilogy which will be lovely
next non-fiction book ah well I know I'm
not sure about that I'm signed up to
sign to write a history of the world
which could be a step too far so that's
that's in a distant future what do you
do when you're not writing and
researching I spend time with my wife
who I love you I love you showing me
that video I mean that's that's a few
years old and it's so lovely to see her
but it's made my whole day it's cheered
me up enormous Lee on this exhausting
nine city tour of America how old are
you two kids now but they're now 15 and
13 either one of them interested in
writing yeah that both quite good at
writing but I don't want to pressure
them because to make a living as a
writer it's a very hard thing and not
many people get to do it so I don't want
to sort of force them into doing any one
thing or either but but it must be funny
for them because we're both men sounds
were both writers and as you can see
she's kind of a delightful person to
live with our guest has been Simon
seabag Montefiore his family is even in
this book I think I'm paid 372 which
people can read called book called the
Romanovs 1613 to 1918 and we thank you
very much for joining us it's lovely to
be here thanks for having me
[Music]
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
Q&A org Q&A programs are also available
as c-span podcasts
[Music]